العلاقات المتوترة بشكل متزايد
داخل العائلة الرابحة ، هذه
قصة رائعة cnn تعلم أن
الشخصين الأقرب إلى الرئيس السابق
خلال فترة وجوده في المنصب
، إيفانكا وصهره جاريد كوشنر ،
كانا في الواقع يبتعدان
عن ترامب ومظالمه المستمرة
حول الاقتباس المسروق من
الانتخابات
ومراسل البيت الأبيض كيت
بينيت موجود هنا
مع التفاصيل حسنًا ، لماذا يحدث هذا
يا كيت جيدًا ، أعني أنني أعتقد تمامًا كما قلت ، من
الواضح أن هذا الرئيس السابق
الذي لا يمكنه المضي قدمًا
والذي يستمر في الحديث عنك
كل شيء بدءًا من من صوره في
وقت متأخر من الليل أه عرض كوميدي كوميدي حتى
الانتخابات التي ما زال يدعيها
أه هل تعلم لم تكن دقيقة ، لذا كان
جاريد وإيفانكا معه طوال
الوقت لدرجة
أنهما صُنعا  مصطلح javonka وهذا
مثير للاهتمام للغاية فهم لا يريدون أن يكونوا
حولهم
ولا يريدون أن يكونوا في مدار
هذا
النوع المستمر من عدم القدرة على
لقد اتخذوا قرارًا
محسوبًا
ومدروسًا للغاية للتراجع
وعدم قضاء الكثير من الوقت مع
الرئيس السابق الذي يصادف بالطبع أنه
والد إيفانكا ووالد جاريد كوشنر
وصفها شخص
ما لزميلتي في القصة غابي أور
بالقول إنها نوعًا ما مثل
الوالد الذي
يبقى أقل وأقل في الحضانة في
الصباح وهو ينزل طفله
مثل جاريد ببطء وقد تراجعت إيفانكا
وترك ورقة رابحة لنفسه  أه تعرف
قدرات مع
الناس من حوله متباينة
من حيث
أه نطاقها ونظريات المؤامرة
والأشخاص الذين يستمعون إليه
وخطابه وهو
لا يزال غير قادر على التخلي عن انتخابات 2020
ليكون واضحًا في ذلك التشبيه
جاريد  إيفانكا هم الوالدان الذين
ينزلون طفلهم
الملقب بالرئيس السابق في
مرحلة ما قبل المدرسة هو